let's uh let's uh do the trivia question
in advance of today's draft next
quarterback to get his first
ring
and uh the quarterbacks who have won a
super bowl in the top 20 highlight of
their only six of the quarterbacks in
the top 40 countdown have won a super
bowl who is next and here's the question
chris who was the last starting
quarterback to lose a super bowl before
winning his first one who was the last
to lose a super bowl before finally
winning his first oh man um i know i'm
gonna know this and i just this is gonna
drive me crazy who is the last one to do
that man is the last one to do that
john elway
i don't know that we play the music
anymore but yes
yes you are correct it was john elway he
lost what how many lose two or three
before he finally won three before he
finally won owen from owen three to 2-3
not a bad way to cap your career all
right you're up
man okay that's actually amazing stat
really and it tells you how hard it is
to overcome losing a super bowl
sometimes i mean that's that's uh the
perfect example all right
you know to me i got to go lamar jackson
here you know one of course i think he's
incredibly talented and
one of the five best quarterbacks in the
league but you know part of this
exercise too to me is you know you got
to pick the team right and baltimore's
still a team that i look at and go
as long as everything goes as planned
and you know there's not a cobia 19
outbreak on the ravens or anything like
that i think that team is still going to
be one of the more exceptional ones in
football this year so i i look at him as
being that guy that's that's first on
this list for me
yeah i don't disagree with that they
were the best team in the regular season
last year they mishandled arguably or
actually that week 17
extra by de facto buy and i think they
were a little bit unprepared a little
bit stale a little bit sluggish on that
saturday night against the titans
otherwise maybe they he would have
gotten his first ring this year i'm
going to stay in the conference i'm
going to slide down to the afc south and
it's amazing to me how all of a sudden
the texans aren't really being taken all
that seriously and i know it has a lot
to do with trading deandre hopkins but
look it doesn't mean they're going to
win their first ring this year right it
might be a couple years before one of
these guys gets his first ring and i'm
gonna go to sean watson i think they're
building something i think he's getting
better every year i think he's being
overlooked i think the texans even
though they keep finding a way to get
back to the playoffs they continue to be
overlooked they continue to have a low
bar that continues to be this perception
of dysfunction i think they're quietly
putting something together where they
they can be a team that that you know in
a division that
sometimes is good sometimes it's not so
good maybe you fatten up your record to
the point where you get the number one
seed learn how to hold a lead in the
playoffs deshawn watson keeps getting
better and better i i uh i'm gonna go
with him now i would go with lamar
jackson if you've gotten the question
wrong but i think the clear number two
in my mind is desean watson
yeah i think so too yeah you know you're
right the only thing i questioned there
was just about
when are they a super bowl caliber team
and they're like they're very close and
you mean you you explained it perfectly
i mean you really did and yes you know
and that afc south
yeah maybe the rosters on the colts and
the tennessee titans are a little bit
better than the houston texans certainly
but when it comes sunday the best player
on the field in those games in the afc
south will be number four that's for
sure and uh that's a great equalizer so
i hear you there all right man i'm
really stuck in this one i don't know
what to do here
i
i i um man
i think i'm going to go
with carson wentz i'm we're not counting
carson wentz getting the ring right that
doesn't count right okay no
that was a phil sims jeff hostetler ring
three years ago
right that's right that's not gonna
react trying to
are you trying to say carson wentz
didn't earn the super bowl ring three
years ago
no i know he was the biggest acl you're
right he is he's a big part of it i mean
actually the story of between him and my
father is very similar
it really is but yeah i'm gonna go with
wentz one yes i think this is an
incredible talent um the only thing that
i think is holding them back is maybe
some of the leadership stuff that we
heard about a little bit last year but i
also i think just my belief in the
eagles and doug peterson and howie
roseman uh and their ability to build
and coach the team the right way uh
they're another team i'm just gonna yeah
i'm gonna look at i think they're gonna
continue to stay relevant they make the
right moves i like everything about them
and i think wentz is still getting
better and better and i think he's
already special so i'm going to go with
him
all right my next pick is a guy who
doesn't have a whole lot of
opportunities to win his first ring he
was extremely close to it a few years
ago he finished in your top ten one spot
behind carson wentz and that's matt ryan
of the falcons and in a year where
there's all this obsession about drew
brees and tom brady combined age of 84
when they meet week one and it's the
saints or the buccaneers that's going to
win that division well maybe maybe they
cancel each other out and maybe the
falcons
who have a very low bar and they have
earned that low bar in recent years they
finished the year six and two
they have a positive vibe going they
still have julio jones they still have
calvin ridley they're trying to beef up
the defense matt ryan is still matt ryan
and again he doesn't have a whole lot of
opportunities left he's now 35
but i i
i would not be shocked if they give us a
little bit of a back to the future 2016
type of a season this year where they
emerge from the nfc south as the the
dominant team while the saints and the
buccaneers are worried about trying to
jockey for a wild card berth chris yeah
mike i'm with you they're one of those
teams that is like a little bit of the
under the radar i would say watch out
sleeping giant type of team because we
all recognize there's talent on their
football team on both sides of the ball
and yeah the quarterback's really good
of course we know the coaching staff is
worthy of bringing the team deep into
the playoffs and being competitive that
way but yeah their big thing is can they
just stay freaking healthy if they can
stay healthy you're right i think we're
all forgetting about the falcons i think
their team is every bit as talented as
tampa bay down there who were all kind
of anointing one of the kings in the nfc
and of course we know the saints are
really good but i'm with you don't
forget about the uh the atlanta falcons
all right
man this is a tough one because
you know there's a part of me like i
maybe think about philip rivers because
i think there's a possibility he could
get that in the next year or two but i'm
gonna go my with chris sims bias here
i'm picking jimmy garoppolo i am because
i'm gonna pick kyle shanahan and that
team and john lynch and everything that
goes along with jimmy garoppolo very
close this year we know that you know
was it his best super bowl performance
or best game we played all year
certainly not jimmy garoppolo we know
that as well uh but i just have the
tremendous faith in shanahan the system
the players around them and i think we
all forget sometimes that last year was
really jimmy garoppolo's first year as a
full starter and he will get better so i
think all those things take into account
uh i'm going with garoppolo
this is a topic that i want to delve
into more deeply in pftot today you'll
be able to find that at the website at
the youtube channel it'll be the
p-f-t-o-t p-f-t-p-m podcast but specific
specific point about garoppolo and the
49ers for 2020.
i don't know that i would have gone
garoppolo because again i don't know the
49ers are going to be in position to win
it all this year i think it's too hard
to do there's only been two teams ever
that have that have won the super bowl
the year after losing the super bowl and
i think by the time they win a super
bowl it may be a different quarterback
of the san francisco 40. i it's risky i
think i think it's up or out this year
for jimmy g but but uh nevertheless my
pick and and look
again just just so we're clear it
doesn't mean that you're likely to win
it this year of all the guys who have
never won a ring at the quarterback
position
the likely to win the next one and i'm
doing it i'm doing it a guy who's never
started an nfl game a guy who is
stepping in the shoes of tom brady jared
stidham
jared stidham
awesome you're doing there max how are
you you want max headroom you were fewer
like right i mean i was kind of scared
there are children at home watching this
and they are fearful now with that giant
head of yours it was right in front of
the camera but i'm going jared stidham
because it's the patriots in bill we
trust it's the system and he wants to
prove and they all want to prove there
was an item in the boston herald within
the past week or so where rodney
harrison
talked to karen gorigen about the
reality of
of what the patriots will be trying to
do this year they hear the noise bill
belichick uses it as motivation they're
going to want to prove they can win
without tom brady they're going to prove
that their system works and whether it's
this year next year or the year after
that yeah do we really think the
patriots are just going to disappear
just because their 42 year old
quarterback is gone so uh give me your
student good for you i thought what i
was getting there first off and kids at
home yeah don't mess with my noggin this
thing is dangerous it's hard as hell
it's got extra layers of bone it's been
hit so many times okay but so you're to
you're like i don't know where you
thought i was going
i thought you might have been going
taste of hill and i was not you know
like wow i thought it was a taste tasted
hill and then i thought maybe you were
gonna say kirk cousins for a second and
i was gonna go he's totally off his
rocker today
i mean i thought your camera froze or
something i mean you held that position
that was impressive but
yeah i i we ha i mean it's a and this
just all sets up so perfectly for the
patriots everybody's just like pushing
pushing them off of the stage they're
gonna push their way back onto the stage
all right we got to take a break because
uh we had to leave some time for just a
little a little look down the past few
months before chris gets his three weeks
and one day break there are the picks
for the next quarterback to get his
first ring
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports